there's a video I saw to France where
during their pride March someone climbed
up to a second floor about someone's
second second floor balcony and ripped
down the French flag it's not just
America it is these all these countries
having some kind of weird shared
internet cult
and they're they're they're bubbling up
in bunch of different countries the
patriarchy they want to smash the
picture oh sure the white privilege no I
think is what it stands they are the
patients times ten like remember
literally wokeness is Hardcore
patriarchy yeah like the the at the the
the the advocacy against the rights of
women is it's crazy it's racist too it
splits up right kids and tells them
their skin color means something like
people become racist and they're like
so so counterproductive it's wild wild
that humans think that this is something